i definitely have to ask you how has
your
in the heights experience maybe prepped
you or helped you shape what you want to
do with wicked
we're in the beginning stages of wicked
however i think the philosophy of
what musicals mean to me personally now
that i have
actually made a movie musical you know
there's theory about what movie musicals
mean to me
as being a watcher of movie musicals now
that i've gone through it
it really what really has hit me is the
power of music
and why musicals exist in the first
place because when words aren't
sufficient
and nowadays words really aren't
sufficient for
what we're going through and and so for
me it's finding the truth
of each song and working our way inside
out of why that exists yes of course
we're going to have oz
and you're going to be in this crazy
world and you're going to revisit this
innocent place and you're going to see
that it's
not as innocent as it had been in the
past but you're also going to see um
that the relationship between these two
women is is more real than ever that
we're going to be that close to them
we're going to
root for them when to try to get into
that school or or when one crosses the
other we're going to root that they
you're going to hate the other one at
some point you're going to want them to
make up at another point you're going to
feel when they separate to me that's
like that's the most important thing the
spectacle that's the easy part we can
hire a lot of people to do that
uh it's it's those little moments who
are going to be able to communicate
those moments
that's that's what's going to make that
do you think you're filming this year
i can't answer that i'll leave